we're following a very personal Journey
today an ex- colleague of ours called
Sarah got in touch with me telling me
that her father had died in the
earthquake he' cycled these roads for
charity and she was so overwhelmed by
the actions of a young Moroccan man
called hemza hamza's family runs the
hotel where her father was supposed to
stay that night um her father was in a
cafe around 8 kilm away from where Hamza
was he went there and managed to
retrieve her father's body now Sarah in
the UK we are here uh so we decided to
make the around 4-Hour Journey deep into
the mountains to go and meet
him I woke up and ran to the stairs he
tells
us Sarah's dad had texted earlier saying
he was staying at the cafe overnight as
he was too tired to cycle up the
mountain the rooms are upstairs he says
but we got everyone out
Hamza is just showing me on his phone he
has a list of the dead of this region
4506 yeah have only one Village is 71
only eight 71 dead in one Village so the
earthquake so far the death total is
almost
3,456 from this area alone it is so
remote here so peaceful and yet you can
see the violence of the earthquake how
it split the ground quite deeply here
and Hamza uh is telling us that 21
members of his village lost their lives
in the Quake that's further down the
valley he takes us to his
house if I'd been sleeping in this bed
that night I would have been dead he
says his parents wife and three children
survived the Quake I was extremely
afraid I thought my family was was gone
the house is destroyed but what would I
do with all of this if ID lost my family
family is everything if they're gone
there is
nothing before we leave we passed by the
cafe where Sarah's father died as we're
approaching the cafe at started ter rain
and you can see how people are trying to
cover their
tent with
tarpan the Cafe's owner joins us this is
where we found him they tell us we
rushed to him but there was nothing we
could do it was God's will Stephanie
Decker or jazer te in test in Morocco's
Atlas
Mountains